- My mom started putting
like a little bit of coffee
in my hot chocolate and the first day
I almost like shit my pants
on the way to my school.
(laughter)
(upbeat music)
- I started drinking coffee
when I was in the second grade.
- It's like the first thing
I drink every morning,
drink it all the way through the day.
- I'm a late coffee adopter
and now I can't stop.
I love it, I need it every day.
- Coffee and me is getting a little
out of control lately in the mornings.
- In terms of like a ratio,
I think it would be like
a two is to one with
sugar and actual coffee.
- Yeah I would say I have
at least one or two cups
of coffee every morning, and that's after
a caffeine pill to go to the gym.
- I have a committed
relationship with coffee.
And I quit smoking a long time ago
and coffee is a great
replacement for that.
(upbeat music)
- [Both] Ooooh.
- Oh.
- Oh, interesting.
- Are there really people who think
they can tell the difference?
- I bet I can tell the difference,
you're sitting next to one.
- I don't believe in decaf coffee.
- Yeah it's stupid.
Why?
- [Both] Why?
- Cheers.
- I can taste the
caffeine in this for sure.
- You can taste the caffeine
- Yes I can taste it.
- Over all the sugar, you can
taste the caffeine molecule?
- Yes I can. (laughter)
- Are you tricking us?
Are they both decaf? (laughs)
- Oh, shit.
- Tastes pretty smooth, like
a standard cup of coffee.
- Isn't it weird that it's
just bean water, though?
- This tastes like nothing.
- Oh, definitely this one.
- It's this one.
- Yeah this one sucked.
- For sure.
- Okay so it's a little harder.
- This one, it feels
like there's something
missing maybe, I don't know.
- Interesting.
I'm gonna say the opposite.
- This one kinda tastes
like gas station coffee.
- Yeah.
This is more watery.
- I'm gonna assume that
you're not tricking us,
because that's just screwing me up.
- I'm gonna be like really
embarrassed if I like
mess this up.
- Mess this up.
- Yeah.
- You drink like five.
- You should know.
- Okay, just 'cause I
wanna be controversial
and because my taste
buds are all messed up,
I'm gonna go this as decaf.
- Caffeinated, decaf.
(buzzing)
- Would bet my firstborn on it.
- I think right is
caffeinated and left is not.
- Okay, I think I'm gonna agree with you.
I think this is, I think
this one's caffeinated,
this one's decaf.
- Final answer, decaf, regular.
- This one right here.
- This one.
- I believe the opposite, I
think right is decaffeinated
and left is caffeinated coffee.
- Yes!
(laughter)
- I got it.
- Damn it.
- I nailed it.
I've been practicing this for 20 years.
- Oh so I was right the first time.
- Oh shit.
- And then I got influenced.
- Yes
- Oh, damn it.
- My coffee senses
are way off.
- It's pointless, I
don't see the use of it.
Unless you like the flavor,
like you actually genuinely
like the flavor and you
don't wanna stay up.
- They're both good though.
I would drink either one of these.
- Actually, yeah, and if
you didn't tell me the decaf
was decaf, I would probably drink it
and feel like I got my coffee for the day.
- So, big supporter of
decaf and I'm embarrassed
that I couldn't tell the difference.
- ABDC, always be drinking coffee.
(upbeat music)